- Hello, wow.
(audience applauding and cheering)
I love this New York
apartment you moved into.
- I know.
It's nice, it's fabulous.
- Great digs.
- I know, I love it.
I actually love being in
this building so much.
We're in the same building now.
- We're in the same building now.
- Yes.
- See you in the elevator.
I love, listen I've had a milkshake burst
in the elevator too.
You're not the only one.
- I dropped my matcha.
- Matcha.
- It went everywhere.
- And listen, we've all
done a Jackson Pollock
in the building somewhere.
- No, it was my first day, man.
(guest laughing)
(audience laughing)
- [Guest] And it's beautiful art.
- [Kelley] It was also on the ceiling.
I think Andy, he caught it.
He was trying to be nice.
It was everywhere.
- That's okay.
- I've actually never had
a drink drop like that.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Well, did it drop or
did it rocket to the sky?
- I swear to God, a ghost
was in the elevator.
I was holding it and then I wasn't
- Right.
- Like, and I was just standing there.
No one bumped me.
Like.
- Spooky.
- It just was like,
"Welcome to the building."
- Yep.
- Like, yeah.
Yeah, so I trash things
when I enter buildings.
It's fine.
Have you ever had any mishaps here?
- Oh, definitely.
- Yeah.
- One time for a dry mishap.
Rachel Maddow almost like, I almost,
Rachel Maddow was trying to open the door
for me once, this glass door
and then I kind of
leaned into it too much.
I could have broken through
the glass and killed us both.
And it would've been a gay
scandal in the building.
For both of us.
- This was a specific scandal.
- Specific scandal, yeah.
- What's your favorite
part of the building?
Because I had no idea, like
the underground situation
happening here.
- Yeah, it's pretty
incredible.
- It's amazing.
- Yeah.
- I have a clear favorite
place in the building
and I took it upon myself to
make a little video for you.
where I.
- I have not seen this.
What is it?
- Was I supposed to set it up?
Oh, great.
- Oh.
- Amazing.
- I literally haven't seen it.
So Yes.
- Hi Kelly, welcome to 30 Rock.
I'm gonna show you my favorite
spot in the entire complex.
Are you ready for it?
It's the Dunkin' Donuts
outside the subway.
Every day I come into work,
I order myself a small iced coffee black
and not a donut, but a banana.
So if anyone's wondering who
on earth is buying the bananas
at Dunkin' Donuts, it's me, right here.
I'm gonna do that right now.
And welcome to New York.
It's been waiting for you.
- Judging you.
- Why?
- I am judging you.
Who goes to Dunkin'
Donuts for a damn banana?
- Oh, I mean, anyone in their right mind.
- I'm walking out with something glazed.
(guest laughing)
- Look, the bananas are perfectly ripe.
And look, if you buy them in
bulk, if you buy multiple.
(Kelly laughing)
Put them at home.
And then once they go soft,
you make banana bread.
- You're like Sam's Clubbing
it at Dunkin' Donut.
- Definitely.
- You getting, buying in bulk.
I like it.
- Yep.
- So this is exciting.
So Bad Bunny is SNL this week,
hosting and musical guests, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause been on but never hosted, right?
- Been on but never hosted.
You know, he played a pirate
in a sketch that I was in.
- Yeah.
- When he was musical guest
and he was amazing as a pirate.
- Okay, good to know.
- And which I think I
can extrapolate to mean
that he would be amazing in
any other capacity as well.
I'm so excited.
- You can nail pirate,
you can nail it all.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the New York of sketchuals.
If you can make it there,
you can make it anywhere.
- I heard too recently,
I didn't get to see it
but I've heard everybody talking about it.
When Taylor surprised and
Kelsey was on there as well.
Was that, I mean 'cause that's hilarious.
- Hilarious.
- How the commentators.
- It's not hilarious how
it is literally taking
over the NFL for people that
like watching sports now.
- And like, you have to watch
like a tutorial in football.
- It's like you're watching "Housewives"
while you're watching.
Yeah, they're just talking
about gossip things
and you're like, "So what about the play?"
- Right?
- Yes, yes.
- I can only imagine.
- But they're taking over.
- Right?
- Yeah, I thought it was funny that y'all.
That's what I love about SNL.
Y'all touch on it like right then.
It's so awesome that it's live
and you're able to like
attack those things.
Like at, on the weekends,
like right when it happens.
- Right, it was crazy.
Like we, no one told us
they were coming.
- Thank them
for fresh material.
- Oh yes.
Yes, thank you Travis and Taylor for that.
It was so wild.
We didn't expect them to come.
I round the corner,
they're at the page desk
and it's like, I'm like,
"Oh, there's two of the
tallest people I've ever seen.
"Who are they?"
- Right.
- "Who is that?"
I was like in the Redwood
Forest or something.
- The mirror woods.
- Yes, yes.
And then I was like, "Oh, my goodness.
"Wow, it's them, okay, they're here."
And it was wild.
- Oh, I love it.
So you went to her Eras Tour right?
- Yes, I went to that, yeah.
- Okay, I wasn't able to make it.
So I imagine it was just.
First of all, it's such
a clever idea to do that
and have everybody go.
'Cause there's so much nostalgia happening
for people that have
been fans for so long.
Were you, have you been
a fan for like a minute?
- I've been a fan for a long minute.
A long day.
- Were you afraid to say decade?
- I was.
And it's, wait, it's been about a decade.
'Cause I really, I
latched on during "Red".
- Oh, great album.
- Yeah, yeah, great album.
No, so it's been a minute.
And you know, we've all grown up with her.
- Yeah.
- And so it was so cool.
I watched it from the
floor and then with Matt.
Matt, my friend Matt Rogers and I went.
And then we, and then
but then seeing the "Eras Tour"
movie is pretty incredible.
- Yeah. 'cause the movie came out, yeah.
- Yes, the movie came out.
- And it was everywhere.
I literally ate at a
restaurant here downstairs
and we were leaving.
Caitlin who was serving us was like,
"Hey, and I made these bracelets."
And she said something and
for the debut or something.
And I was like, I just went along with it.
I was like, "Thank you, that is so nice."
And then I walked off and we were like
what are they talking about?
And they were, they people are so into it.
They were making, people
just randoms are making
like bracelets passing them out to like.
She's got such an incredible street team.
- I know.
- I was like, yeah.
- It's really amazing.
- But yeah, so the movie came out
and it like busted all
these like, you know.
- Records.
- Stats and records.
Yeah, yeah.
Which is not shocking, it's Taylor.
- Not at all.
- Yeah, but I love that
you've been a fan for so long.
I think we've all been a fan of her music.
She's a great writer.
Like she's got so many great songs.
That was the look at his new
movie "Dicks: The Musical".
It's in theaters everywhere.
Explain the movie.
- Okay, it is a very adult
take on "The Parent Trap".
But it's a musical.
Don't bring your kids please.
- An adult take on "The Parent Trap"?
- Yes, yes.
- Okay.
- So these two businessmen
meet each other at work.
They find out they're
separated twins from birth.
They plot to bring their
parents back together.
I'm sort of the narrator.
Kinda like a "Rocky
Horror Picture" situation
where I'm narrating as God, the Almighty.
- You get to play God.
- I get to play God.
And then you had Alanis
Morissette on earlier.
- I know she's played God.
- She's played God.
It's me, Alanis, Morgan
Freeman, George Burns.
We're the "Sex and the City" Girls of God,
the Mount Rushmore.
- Those could not be
more different people.
- I know.
- That's incredible.
- It's pretty (indistinct).
- Everyone could be God, I like it.
- Everyone could be God.
- Joan Osborne was right.
So music, if you're, yeah
under 40, you don't get it.
So wait, so did you always
like musicals growing up?
Were you into musicals?
- Oh yeah.
- Okay.
- Of course, absolutely, like, it's just.
- Do you remember your first one you saw
that you really loved?
- I think my first one I saw was probably
"The Sound of Music" and.
- Okay, good.
- Undeniable.
Oh yeah, give it up.
(audience applauding)
"The Sound of Music".
- No, I was just saying.
I think it was like
"Sound of Music" for me.
And also "Funny Girl".
I don't know which one I saw first
but those were the, and I was
like, "This is incredible."
- Yes, right.
- Yeah.
- It's undeniably good.
And then like, I just,
I would take out like
literally anything I could
find from the library.
Like "Wicked" and I can't
think of anything else.
That's the only musical
- Your age is shining through
with "Wicked" as one of your inspirations.
- It was.
- 'Cause I was like, "Wait."
I was like, "That was so."
Wait, have you ever played,
did you play a court jester?
Did I hear like?
- I was the jester's understudy
in "Once Upon a Mattress".
(audience applauding)
- Oh, wait, so that's always hurt me.
'cause I had to do, in high
school there's a double cast.
It's complicated.
- Right, right.
- And I learned all this
music and it wasn't understudy
but it was like double cast,
which really was understudy.
'Cause I only got one
show, I'm pretty sure.
- Big school?
- And you learn all that stuff.
- You learned all the stuff for one night.
- For oh.
- Yeah.
- I was like it was a lot.
Yeah, literally was like one performance.
And it was like, you, do you
get, is there a little anger
in that or resentment that
you learn all of that?
- No.
- No, are you lying?
- I'm lying.
- Okay.
Because I learned all this
stuff and it was so much.
- I just felt like.
- Do you pray that they get sick?
- No, oh my goodness.
You're about to show girls people.
- I wouldn't either.
I mean, just one, like
a little cold, you know.
Just a little cold for one time, yeah.
- A tickle in the throat.
- It's a lot of material to learn.
- It is.
Okay, was it double cast
because they just wanted
to make everybody happy?
Like, all the kids happy at school?
- We'll go with that.
- Okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we'll go with that.
- I mean gosh, I'm sure
they're kicking themselves now.
Like, "Oh, we only gave Kelly
Clarkson one night on stage."
- It wasn't about me.
It was "Seven Brides for Seven Brothers".
That's a huge double cast.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it taught me a lot
about just working hard,
just 'cause you love it.
- Quote unquote.
- We saw this photo though.
This is Little Bowen and I
just think it's adorable.
So like, wait, like what birthday is this?
You're so cute.
- I think this is five.
I think I'm five years old.
- What's your cake?
Do you remember?
I think it was -
- I was trying to to figure it out.
- It looks like maybe like
Dollar Store Power Rangers
or something.
I don't know.
I don't, we we couldn't tell like
like the producers of
the show and I were like.
- Dollar Store?
- Totally.
"What is that?"
And like, they didn't know, obviously.
And I was like, "I don't
think I know either."
But if you look at that photo
I'm using my full cheek power.
- Yes.
- Look at that.
- I know, but I was convinced
if I didn't blow them all
out in one breath, my
wish was null and void.
Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, I still think that.
- Yeah, me too.
I am 41 spitting on cake.
- Yep, yep.
- I am like (imitates blowing).
It's like a full on, yeah,
I don't wanna miss out
on my wish.
- Right.
- I heard this as well,
which is kind of odd to me.
Your math teacher got you into comedy?
- He did.
- What is the, how does that?
- How does that work?
- How does that happen?
- Was he a very funny math teacher?
- He was a very funny math teacher.
- Okay.
- He was cool.
He moonlit as an assistant director
at a comedy theater in Denver, Colorado.
- Oh okay, this tracks, okay.
- It tracks, right.
And he and like the sort
of crown jewel of being
in the drama club at our, you
know, big public high school
was being on the improv group.
- Yeah.
- And there were only like eight people.
Was not a double cast situation.
- Yeah.
You were important.
- Well, yeah, yeah.
But, you know, you couldn't
audition if you were a freshman.
You had to wait till your sophomore year.
I didn't get into my sophomore year.
And then I got in my junior,
it was this whole saga.
And then I happened to be good
at math with my glasses and.
(audience laughing)
And then like I was a good student
and I was a good, you
know, little improv kid
but you know, I was 14
years old going downtown
like bombing in front of beer drinkers.
It was so strange.
- But it's, that's kind of awesome though.
It probably built up so much character
and like, and armor.
You know what I'm saying?
- Totally.
- To be able to take the hecklers,
to be able to take all that, yeah.
- I mean, not to bring
in your personal history.
Like, I can't imagine like,
being on like a national slash
world stage in my early as a performer.
Like that for you, that's like a lot.
- Well, imagine you
have no money, no house.
You're living in your car
and you're like, "Sure."
You're like, like, yeah I
think that helps though.
I'm being funny.
But like, I do think that helps.
Like when people say,
"Are your kid's gonna
get in the industry?"
I'm like, "I don't really know,
man, if they can handle it."
Like when you have nothing
you have nothing to lose.
So it's like, you know you go for anything
and say yes to everything.
- Totally.
- Yeah, so I think it's
maybe a little bravery.
Maybe just like I needed to pay my bills.
- Sure, sure, sure.
- Yeah.
- That'll do it.
Did you have those
moments in this industry?
'cause nobody really makes
it, like right off the bat.
Like everybody thinks Idol was
the first thing I ever did.
- Of course, of course.
- I lived on a mattress in
an apartment and whatever.
- Right.
- But did you have those
moments where you're like,
"Is this gonna hit?"
- Oh yeah, I mean.
Did you ever have like, you
know, ramen noodle weeks
or anything?
- I'm sorry, did I live on it?
- Yeah, oh yeah.
By the way, still love stuff.
- 39 cents a thing.
Yeah, my daughter's obsessed with it.
- Ah, she.
- And I feel like a bad parent
giving it to her, but like.
- No, no, no, look how I turned out.
- Well, we can afford, we're fine.
- We're fine.
- We're fine, no, I do.
I feel like a bad parent.
I'm like, I should probably
cook you something else.
But she loves it.
- She loves this.
Put it, crack a egg in
it, put some scallions.
It's lovely.
- Oh, fancy.
- Yeah.
- Meanwhile my son eats anything
the color of your shirt.
Yeah, yep.
- Me too.
- Yeah, he's like, "Cool, bread."
Let's do another break everybody.
Bowen's movie "Dicks:The Musical"
is in theaters nationwide
and the soundtrack is also available now.